and I think that's the case we kind of
worry about is just that they really
don't care about us because we're just
so unevolved it wouldn't even cross
their mind twice to delete our planet if
that was in the way of them doing some
project they were interested in doing I
kind of have this crazy hypothesis that
I think the most likely communication
we'll have will be with a civilization
on its way out one that's desperate we
listen but we do not communicate really
much into space we don't have an active
program of sending out messages saying
hey we're here can please come hang out
with us there's a few individuals which
are interested in doing this around the
world but it's pretty controversial you
know Stephen Hawking famously hated the
idea of doing mey he thought it was
crazy dangerous we should definitely not
be sending out messages we should just
stick to our own uh World until we've
sort of got very mature but I think
Stephen Hawking might have changed his
mind if we were a civilization that was
on the verge of
collapse